antonio brown had his meeting with art
rooney earlier this week the end result
the steelers will try to trade him but
we learned the next day from gm kevin
colbert that they're not just going to
give him away they want significant
compensation assuming they can get
something that will make them happy
brown gets traded potential
arguable maybe future hall of fame
receiver getting sent to a new team i
guess whether he'd get to canton would
depend upon what he does with that new
team plenty of great players have been
traded over the years today's draft best
players ever traded big cat as always
you will call tails
and you will win the toss because the
toss is rigged and then you'll defer to
me off we go
tails
there we go
sims has been trying to mess with me
lately and call heads and he's been
losing the toss oh it's heads
all right well i will not defer i am
going to take uh the guy who was traded
right out of the gates he was drafted by
the baltimore colts back in 1983 he told
the colts don't draft me i won't play
for you i'll play baseball instead they
traded him to the denver broncos and he
went wire to wire his entire career in
denver one of the best five maybe best
three quarterbacks of all time john
elway easy one thank you coin toss uh
and uh big cat you're up
okay i'll go with good pick mike good
pick i will go with a hall of famer as
well marshall falk who was traded from
the cults to the rams when he was traded
he was one of the best backs in the
league i think he had i'm looking at it
right now his year in indianapolis he
was 20 25 years old and he had 1300
rushing yards 86 targets or sorry 86
catches 900 receiving yards he was kind
of the new mold of running back traded
in his prime went to st louis they win a
super bowl the greatest show on turf he
was a big part of that
that is my first pick
would you say marshall falk is one of
the five best running backs of all time
i'd have to i mean quickly off top my
head walter payton barry sanders emmitt
smith uh
who am i missing
curtis martin peterson with danny and
tomlinson
the danny and tomlinson adrian i don't
yeah i'd say he probably isn't in that
discussion for top five right i i i i'm
trying to prop up your pick jim brown
yeah i think jim brown better marshall
anyway my point is you left brett favre
on the board one of the top five
quarterbacks of all wait wait i got two
of the top five quarterbacks of all time
no i'm in the process of dominating you
don't make me stop
no you're not dominating me because
brett favre was not good when he was
traded we're talking about best players
ever to get traded antonio brown is
great and he got traded marshall fox was
great and he got traded i'll give you
john elway because he was the he was a
phenomenal he's a no doubter first pick
but now you're picking a guy who is
whose first pass from from the line of
scrimmage was an interception right or
no was it to him no it was an
interception so you're talking about a
guy who wasn't that good when he was
traded your whole your whole argument
here is falling apart i i think you have
misunderstood the definition of the
draft the player doesn't have to be the
best ever who was traded it's the best
player who was traded it's all where the
emphasis is best player who was traded
not when the best way no
that's the word when isn't in there big
cat okay see all right listen listen i i
you know i you i know that you i know
that you think highly of your lawyer
skills but the word when isn't in
they're not best player when he was
traded best player who was traded well
you would make the assumption right the
implication is with antonio brown best
player to be traded that would be that'd
be fair right no one talked about brett
favre when he was traded
that would be a [ __ ] assumption all
right fine then you know what i'll go
with steve young for my next one super
bowl winner hall of famer trading from
the bucks to the niners if we're going
to just go willy nilly here and not care
how the player was
when they were traded
i'll go with steve young for my next
pick
well and now i have to go and and that
look
he was he was one of these guys uh with
the buccaneers who you know when they
were talking about are they done with
jameis winston they've had plenty of
guys who have passed through tampa and
gone on to be pretty good elsewhere
whether it's vinnie testa verdi whether
it's steve young and that was one of the
concerns like if you let go of jameis
winston maybe he goes somewhere else and
he ends up being much better than he's
ever been in tampa bay and steve young
is really the shining example of that
the buccaneers had him the buccaneers
let him go and he ended up being a hall
of famer with the san francisco 49ers
all right i am uh look when you think of
the circumstances and again
my standard isn't best player when
traded just best player who was traded
randy moss was
by all accounts washed up the patriots
gave up a fourth round pick for him
during the 2007 draft some people
thought that was too much nobody thought
he could run anymore he had become
completely disengaged in oakland and as
it turned out he just didn't care it
wasn't that he couldn't play it's that
he didn't care about playing he didn't
care about playing for the raiders he
went to new england and had one of the
best if not the very best seasons for a
receiver in nfl history set the single
season receiving touchdown record
breaking jerry rice's mark of 22 moss in
2007 incredibly only played for three
years and part of a fourth one with the
patriots but best player ever traded
randy moss well at least my third round
pick okay
best best player wilts
best player wilts being traded
so while they were they were traded they
were the best player that's what i'm
doing that's what i'm drafting two
separate finish i'm gonna finish with
the trade that happened this past season
yeah that's cool mack
that's that's a that's a hall of famer
hall of fa oh that's a pretty good pick
that's a pretty good pick
in the prime of his career if it listen
i i had a totally different
interpretation of the rules here because
who cares about a trade where hey look
brett favre yeah he got traded i think
got traded for a first round pick but no
one really knew that he was going to be
great steve young which is actually
hurting my own case he got traded he was
bad with the bucks i was about to
dominate you because listen the antonio
brown is a pro bowl player is a hall of
famer and he's being traded with still
some miles left in his tank right so
khalil mack
and marshall faulk that is a great
example
to what is happening with antonio brown
a guy being traded in his prime still
with a lot of good football left
i i think that and i don't want to go
too far behind the curtain here but
stats put a bunch of selections below
the grid and you could just tell from
the names that were selected that it
isn't best player at the time he was
traded because it was eli manning being
traded from the charger
it should and you know because that's
what antonio brown is that's the
discussion how even not to go even
farther behind the curtain but that cell
phone device you carry around and you
get text messages from us about what
we're going to do if you have any
questions
they can be asked it's very i never have
questions asking dominated weakness yeah
and then and dominated all right any
others that we should you know steve
largent was actually traded not that he
was going to make my top but he's a hall
of famer he was traded by the oilers he
was a very late round draft pick back
when they had like 50 rounds of the
draft he was traded to
the seahawks by the oilers in 76 did you
know that
i did not know that uh terrell owens
obviously we talked about earlier in the
show he would definitely be on the list
he's been was he traded twice yeah
he was trading yes and actually they
tried to trade him to the ravens and he
balked at that there was a grievance
that was filed and the end result was
the 49ers traded him to the eagles
instead he was not traded twice though
he was cut by the eagles and signed by
the cowboys he was traded once but
technically tried to trade him twice
because they tried to trade him to
baltimore he was like a raven for a day
so never forget
eric dickerson if under your under your
standard you should have taken eric
dickerson over marshall falk frankly uh
dickerson had 2 105 rushing yards with
the rams and he was traded a couple
years after that uh how many catchers
and how many catches i don't know 21
2105. nobody cares about how many packs
as a running back catches uh champ
bailly was a great player when he was
traded he would have been under your
standard one of the guys to consider i
see statue put herschel walker in here
herschel walker was never a great nfl
player i mean not nearly as great as we
thought he was going to be he was
fantastic at college he had ridiculous
numbers for the new jersey generals i
never felt like he lived up to his
potential at the nfl level he played
forever but i felt like he never
completely and totally became the guy we
thought he was going to be he was good
but he wasn't the guy we thought he was
going to be
what about joe flacco
under your rules joe flacco
super bowl winner
he got he's going to get he's about to
be traded best best player to be traded
in the next few weeks
he's been traded yet hasn't been traded
yet so has not blacco's not the list
jerome bettis another one that i had on
my list hall of famer was solid with the
rams but we think of him
more uh for his time with the pittsburgh
steelers he spent a couple years with
the rams but
the rams i mean they traded for marshall
faulk but they traded away eric
dickerson and jerome bettis and and you
know marshall falk actually played with
peyton manning for one year they picked
up edgar and james after they traded
marshall falk so it worked out well for
the cults but boy if they had kept
marshall falcon indianapolis i know he
wasn't happy with his contract and etc
but if you'd had marshall faulk with
peyton manning and marvin harrison uh
maybe it wouldn't have been until 2006
that they won a super bowl in
indianapolis
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports